على انغام اوتار العود العراقيين ينطلق
موسم جديد من المهرجان الثقفي السنويه
الاشهاري في العراق على حدائق ابي نواس
ببغداد بالتزامن مع اقامته في ست مدن
عراقيه اخرى
[موسيقى]
النسخه التاسعه من مهرجان انا عراقي انا
اقرا قدمت هذا العام اكثر من 75 الف كتاب
الى الجمهور بشكل مجاني نصفها في العاصمه
بغداد والنصف الاخر كان من نصيبي محافظات
البصره نينوى الانبار ميسان ديالى
والديوانيه الكتب المقدمه في المهرجان
يتبرع بها اتحاد الادباء والكتاب العراقي
وعدد من دور النشر والاشخاص المهتمين كل
موسم بنشوف انه الاعداد الجيد العوائل
بدها تيجي هنانا على مود اولا تغيير جو
ثانيا الناس تنتقم بالاصدقائهم اللي ما
شايفهم ثالثا يقتلون الكتب المهرجان وتحول
خلال السنين الماضيه الى ملتقى اجتماعيا
اكثر من كونه حدثا ثقافيه
التي تناغم كل الاعمار جعلتهم مناسبا لكل
افراد الاسره
المبادره انه نلقى اشياء متنوعه همم
بها يعني زوايا مختلفه ومسابقات فكر ما
مقتصر الموضوع فقط على الكتب همم اكو
زاويه للاطفال للرسم تذكار راحل مثل مظفر
النواب بالمستقبل الى توسعه هذه المنظمه
او هاي المبادره ونخلي العراق كله يقرا ان
شاء الله
اليه القائمون على اداره المهرجان يتمثل
باخراجه من مراكز المدن الى المناطق
البعيده لاصال الكتب اليها وتحفيز اهلها
على القراءه